you wanna hear a cool story about that
the founder of Pandora his name's Tim
Weston I went and met with him when I
went and met with him we were good we
went out to lunch and he's like oh I
forgot to do something look you can you
walk with me and I walk with them and
then we go and he goes I gotta get a
haircut so I just sit next to him and
this guy's worth probably $600 we go to
Supercuts right and he gets a haircut
for $12 and we're sitting there in the
barber shop it's on a Tuesday at 1:00 no
one's there and he's telling me the
story I go what did you used to do how
did you go Pandora
he goes here's what I would do Monday to
Thursday he goes I had a CEO who ran the
company I would go I would just he goes
this was a little bit for social media
was around he said I would email people
and I would say I'm gonna be at this
library in New York at this time any
Pandora users in the area come and talk
to me and he said he did that for four
years and he goes here's the first one I
did and he showed me a picture of him at
a coffee shop he goes two people showed
up and he was here's the last one I did
he showed me a picture and it was out of
the library and there was two or three
thousand people there he goes I would do
that Monday to Thursday I did meetups
everywhere all I did was travel and I
did it for years and it worked out if he
goes he goes I was like did it work he
goes every time I did it like he was it
would take a little while but after a
couple years of doing it I would go to
the South are good Atlanta and we would
see more advertisers come so it was just
like he goes it worked out perfectly
right and because I said the same thing
I go wow that's a horrible waste of time
he goes no it worked we made a lot of
money off of it and I got to connect
with users and I would relay the
feedback back to this write my CEO and
they would do it yeah so that case he's
not trying to grow Pandora's active user
base he's taking fans and turning them
into diehards and he's he's generating
advertising revenue which you can get
that actually scales enough to where you
can get advertisers and he's getting
feedback firsthand which is like great
for the product to get better that's a
dope story it's do I love I love I love
that story
[Music]
you